pas toujours facile de respecter la
distanciation lors d'une visite
officielle devant les élèves
même le ministre en convient vous savez
pourquoi
d'abord vous savez qui je suis mais
l'objet de la visite de jean michel
blanquer
c'est bien de conforter les débuts de la
campagne de tests salivaires dans les
écoles à l'avant cours des infirmières
scolaires ont recueilli les échantillons
se sont en particulier elle qui seront
sollicités dans les semaines à venir on
va essayer de la mettre en place avec
les moyens que l'on aura pas ce qu'il
faut voir aussi les moyens des
laboratoires puisque c'est eux qui
doivent analyser aussi donc il faut
qu'ils aient les moyens de les analyser
de pouvoir rendre les résultats des
infirmières scolaires de moins en moins
nombreuses dans les écoles alors qui
d'autre pour atteindre l'objectif
ambitieux du gouvernement trois cent
mille tests par semaine en france dès la
mi mars
il ya un protocole qui est définie de
manière précise comme tous les
protocoles sanitaires
donc là en l'occurrence sont des
personnels spécialisés qui viennent des
agences régionales de santé et ensuite
les le reste des personnels de
l'éducation nationale peuvent être
volontaires pour aider mais pour aider
notamment dans la supervision vis-à-vis
des enfants
ou parfois le suivi administratif de ce
qui se passe car la polémique a vite
enflé ces derniers jours des enseignants
ont pu penser qu'ils seraient mis
directement à contribution
certains documents ans selon les
syndicats laissé planer le doute
claire effectivement et avoir des
consignes qu'ils ne soient pas mises en
place en fonction des académies en
fonction des recteurs rectrice enfin
voilà il faut quelque chose de clair de
national qui définissent les tâches de
chacune et chacun dans le cadre de nos
missions
90 % des parents avaient donné leur
accord soixante dix huit enfants de
l'avant cours ont donc été testé ce
matin résultats sous 48 heures